hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Star Wars Q&A thank you
everybody it's any questions on my
trailer video hopefully you were able to
stop crying long enough to go to school
this morning or go to work but let's get
going so first question squeaker kid
asks why did the TIE fighter shoot green
lasers in the rebel shoot red lasers I'm
so confused
that's actually exactly why they tune
things to certain colors on screen so
that it's really easy to understand just
from a visual perspective you know who
is fighting who or even if it's not a
battle scene you know different groups
of characters have different color
schemes with their costumes like the
resistance characters they dress a
certain way they have a certain color
palette the Imperial characters are I
should say the first-order characters
they have their own color palette too so
say you were deaf or you were taking a
deaf person to the movie and they
couldn't hear what the characters were
saying they'd be able to look at the
screen and know who is who so the TIE
fighters shoot green lasers so that it's
easy you know when there's a lot of
action on screen and things are moving
really fast you'll be able to tell who
is firing on who and because they've
always been green so it's kind of a
double answer next question Kamino asks
do you think that Han or someone from
the original trilogy will die in these
movies I have a bad feeling on Han Solo
but he is definitely like a high a high
likelihood of han Solo
but this Daisy Ridley picture here I'll
just put it up right now there's a lot
of people think that she is crying over
to Baca I guess you know just thinking
that this might be fir down here now
just because she's crying doesn't mean a
character's died but she seems really
upset in this movie so very clearly
somebody close to her is probably going
to die the thing is is we really don't
know what her relationship is relative
to the other characters when the movie
picks up presumably this will be about
the new characters coming together poe
dameron finn and rey and then
intersecting with the original trilogy
characters so about like the third act
of the film she will probably be firmly
on team resistance the thing about
killing original trilogy characters are
is that it has to feel natural to the
plot like it can't be gimmicky and it
has to be someone that will make you
crap your pants but won't make you quit
the movie they're not trying to
intentionally harm the audience so you
have to ask yourself on the list of
characters that it's most unforgivable
to kill who is like the lowest on that
totem pole now they kill Chewbacca in
the books a long time ago they've
already kind of retcon that out with
episode 7 like they've already changed
the expanded
universe because of that so the phantom
had already processed Chewbacca's death
and made their peace with it then I
think he would probably be the most okay
of characters that it is not okay to
kill I mean it's still not okay to kill
characters that you love but if they
don't kill anybody then the resistance
starts to feel invincible so you know
killing a beloved character is one way
to let you know that there is a threat
next question Ignacio asks do you think
that kylo Ren might be Luke's kid if not
why the obsession with Darth Vader how
is he force sensitive well I mean this
is all about the force awakening the
force is this mysterious intelligent
alive thing so naturally it's going to
pop up in unexpected places I should
actually say this right now what I'm
really hoping is is they don't over
explain the force we don't need to know
exactly how the force works part of its
magic is in its mystery that's why a lot
of people got really upset with the idea
of midi-chlorians they're like oh you
mean the force isn't like this
mysterious Zen thing it's like a
biological thing you're just born with
so yes there is like a genetic
hereditary aspect to the force and yes I
definitely think that kylo ren's tied to
the original trilogy characters in a
familiar way I don't I don't want to you
know try to get into too many spoilers
it's all really rumors at this point but
no I do not think he is Luke Skywalker's
son
I don't expect Luke Skywalker to have
any children in the movie I think he'll
be more of an obi-wan character although
depending on what material you're
looking at obi-wan also had a child
himself too or at least a relationship
with someone just trying to base a lot
of your theory crafting on established
Canon typically actual stories you know
in all movies and TV tend to be a lot
simpler than what fan theories make them
out to be so just make your theories as
simple as possible based on the material
we've seen and what we know about the
original trilogy characters like Luke
Skywalker probably kind of went off into
the wilderness to study the force by
himself so he probably didn't have a lot
of time to have children if anyone in
the series is going to be having
children it's gonna be han and Leia and
I don't think they're doing Jason and
Jana but I do think that some of these
characters I mean I think it's pretty
obvious when you look at the poster here
but I think their children will be a big
part of the movie
next question Megan honor asks I've
never seen a Star Wars film but I'm
planning on catching up with the film
series until the new movies come out in
what order do I have to see them not
interested in else weird stories just
the basics
so yeah I mean you're just talking about
the main films well there's two
different ways to watch it you could do
it episode 1 to 6 and that story really
becomes like the fall and redemption of
Vader or you could watch the original
trilogy first and then go back and watch
the prequels and that makes the story a
little bit more about Luke so really it
just depends on which character you
think is the main protagonist of the
series is Star Wars a story all about
Darth Vader or is it a story about Luke
Skywalker redeeming his father it just
changes the narrative a little bit
depending on which order you watched the
movies in so it depends on who your
favorite character is like if your
favorite character is Luke didn't watch
the original trilogy first then watch
the prequels but if you're a hardcore
Darth Vader fan then just watch it
episode 1 - episode 6 you also have to
remember that Clone Wars the animated
movie that came before the TV series is
also canon - so you could add that movie
into technically there's seven films
next question mofo asks who will be the
new bounty hunters or hunters Thursday I
mean there's definitely gonna be new
bounty hunters if you remember all those
scenes with Darth Vader talking to
bounty hunters with Ben hunter droids
non-human bounty hunters they're gonna
be all kinds of those in the new movie
they haven't revealed who any of them
are gonna be yet but I'm actually really
excited to see new bounty hunter droids
that there's actually a bounty hunter
battle droid in the novel's right now
but if you're a big Old Republic fan
then you know you're looking for a
hunter killer droids to show up all that
stuff is gonna be in there yes lots of
bounty hunters employed by the first
order just the same way Darth Vader
employed bounty hunters kylo Ren has
this vision quest to complete Vader's
mission so he needs to track a lot of
stuff down and if he's obsessed with
Darth Vader it makes sense that he would
try to track down those original trilogy
characters to kill the last of the Jedi
and get Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber
next question Lou Rick asks another
lightsaber question do you think that
they're setting Rey up to have a dual
bladed lightsaber it'd be nice to see
one again based on what they've said
about the movie it sounds like there
aren't going to be Jedi all over the
place building lightsabers as in you
know finding Anakin Skywalker's
lightsaber is a huge deal they're become
incredibly rare I do think that Rey is
totally force sensitive and she will
become a Jedi during this new trilogy
Kathleen Kennedy wouldn't harp on the
role of women in Star Wars if she
weren't gonna let one of them become a
Jedi in the movie it'd be completely
disingenuous but I think her path
is gonna be similar to Luke Skywalker's
path in the original trilogy he kind of
got the handicap because they gave him
his father's lightsaber when he first
started out but eventually he
constructed his own lightsaber so what
I'd like to see is Ray not start out
with a lightsaber and construct her own
over the course of the new trilogy and
just double bonus if it happens to be a
double bladed lightsaber but even if she
doesn't fight with a lightsaber in the
first movie you have to remember that
you can use the Force to strengthen
normal melee objects so she can still
use her staff like a non-lethal version
of a lightsaber just whack the out
of people next question and Jack asks
c-3po isn't in any of the footage
I wonder why well I think there are a
couple reasons one because they mostly
want to focus on the new characters
that's why there's so little of the
original cast and two because he
actually looks a little bit different he
has some like some red coloring on one
of his arms I think that they just try
not to give away what has happened to
c-3po since the last trilogy he's a
droid they can keep repairing him so
obviously he and r2 are still around and
whatever happened to c-3po might end up
being spoilery too so they're just
they're holding back on that next
question Sam asks what do you think that
leis upset about does this mean Luke is
dead well no I mean it doesn't mean that
Luke is dead it just means she's really
upset about what's been happening it
looks like the resistance gets its ass
handed to it if you remember the way
Empire Strikes Back ended just with the
rebels and all the main characters
getting the kicked out of them by
the Empire and Darth Vader I think
that's why she's sad like you know a
bunch of people probably dying she has
the weight of the resistance on her
shoulders and also throwing some theory
crafting on there possibly some of her
children are main characters and are
doing things that are making her very
upset nobody can hurt you like family
members can next question Alec asks do
you think that Finn is going to get
trained by Luke well supposedly Luke is
gonna be a bigger thing during episode 8
so I think that there'll be a lot of
Jedi training in that movie like Episode
seven is all about discovery getting the
lightsaber episode eight will be pushing
deeper into that just to go back to
Empire Strikes Back
Luke you have to go to the Dagobah
system to learn from Yoda they'll
probably be a similar arc at some point
in the new trilogy so they might put
that off to Episode eight so regardless
of like other rumors about Luke I do
think that he'll be a conduit for the
new characters learning more about the
force but he won't be the only person
the person talking in the trailer to
Daisy Ridley saying
the force is calling to you let it in I
think that's Lupita's character but the
new characters will learn about the
force the dark side piecemeal from all
kinds of different sources until
eventually like episode 8 or episode 9
they go to the source they go to Luke
who can explain everything in great
detail next question and Jonathan asks
how about it 104 do you think that
that's the new Death Star showing off
its firepower also have you seen inside
Llewyn Davis Adam driver Oscar Isaac and
Justin Timberlake sing a song about
outer space pretty awesome in retrospect
yeah that's totally coincidence you know
people don't plan things out like that
the way they cast movies I definitely
think that that is the star killer base
in a moment similar to when Princess
Leia watched Alderaan be destroyed the
matically a lot of moments in the new
films will hearken back to moments in
the original trilogy they're just
they're mixing and matching a lot of
characters but you also have to remember
that trailers are cut a little
misleading so the scene with kylo Ren
and Poe Dameron might not come right
before this weapon looks like it's
getting tested this could be completely
unrelated but I mean they have a super
weapon they're probably gonna destroy a
planet test it out and make one of the
good characters watch like look at what
this can do there's no hope for you give
up now thank you so much though for so
many questions this is gonna be so much
fun
I'll pry start doing a lot more Star
Wars in November I don't know how many
more clips and trailers were gonna get
but we probably will see some new stuff
they're doing some new weird things
trying to market the film so a lot of
the new information we get actually
comes from like toy releases or video
games there'll be some battlefront stuff
happening really soon too but
congratulations to my Star Wars giveaway
winner ahel' Hossein you in to IMAX
passes for Star Wars in December so be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel and we can work out
the details so I can find a way to get
this stuff to you what I'm gonna do I
think you know for my next couple Star
Wars giveaways like whenever I do Star
Wars videos is I'll just do ticket
giveaways just because it seems like
it's really hard for people to get
tickets in don't worry there are
actually still a lot of tickets
available online so you should be able
to get one no problem worst case
scenario you just you can't see it on
Thursday night you have to wait till
Friday to see it what's gonna happen
next is is there's a new episode of the
flash tonight I'm gonna post my video
for it after that airs I'll have a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
so just look out for that if you guys
aren't watching the flash it is freaking
awesome this year and I am gonna do a
Gotham
- it'll just post a little bit later in
the week so as I post new videos I'll
just provide updates on videos that I've
rescheduled they're just so much Star
Wars stuff at the beginning of the week
I just had to move some stuff around
while you guys wait for all that flash
stuff to post you can click here for my
episode 2 video to catch up on that ant
you can click here for all my Star Wars
footage just you know loop the trailer
like a billion more times just it's okay
to cry totally okay so thank you so much
for watching everybody let's try and
high five I'll see you guys a little bit